foreign
welcome to the Ramsey Show
um so my uh wife and I were just
recently married five months ago
congratulations
thank you I appreciate it
um so since getting married I adopted um
uh a bit of debt which is something that
I'm not too familiar with you adopted it
well
um most of it was is not mine came with
a package oh okay okay okay okay man I
was slow on the uptick on that one dude
my bad sorry so she had a bunch of debt
that's now y'all's dead
yes exactly Hey listen on behalf of
wives everywhere thank you for your
gentle language that you adopted it as
though it was like a sweet puppy yeah it
was her cat that was very loving of you
man
good for you so how much debt did you
adopt so
um
a hundred thousand
um so you adopted like a hippopotamus
not a puppy this is not a puppy okay
okay yeah a large a large puppy yeah all
right 100 Grand and what's your
household income
yeah the household income is a it's
about 58
okay and you two are on the same page
about attacking all of this I assume
uh yes here we are good how can we help
so um
I guess my question is uh just uh
you know that is something that I'm not
too familiar with so uh yeah advice we
got that that's your nice way of saying
stressing your butt out I got you yeah
so I guess this uh advice on how to how
to tackle this debt um as promptly as
possible while still being able to uh
enjoy
um being newly married and um kind of
establishing
um our house and our
um bringing in uh you know furnace
furnace uh Furniture into our apartment
and also
um a dream of ours is to one day uh
start a business together so how did
this I guess navigate all that do you
want the truthful answer or do you want
the uh Pinterest answer
uh truth or answer I'm not huge on
Pinterest so I'm not interested I didn't
know Pinterest was lies but that's
pretty yeah it's just butterflies it's
just pretty pictures is what I'm saying
yeah yeah yeah
um yeah truthful answer please
I think my wife and I were married 10
years because of the whole I dug
when we both were participated but
mostly me
um
to the tune of six figures and a whole
bunch of degrees
before I finally was able to
buy a
uh headboard on Craigslist that I spray
painted in my backyard
here's what I'm telling you
long term in your marriage the smartest
thing to do right now is to pay your
debts off
borrow Furniture get crummy for get to
the next stage man but you have this
picture of what you thought your first
year marriage was going to be like and
you'll have six figures in debt and you
can have all the pretty Furniture in the
world and all the nice cars in the world
and all the new businesses and that debt
will bury your marriage and I know that
because I I've done it I lived it
and I kept punting it and moving it
around and trying to do this and putting
things off instead of just sucking it up
and getting that stupid stuff paid off
here here's what's weird
um when you guys
decide together
and you take her two hands and your two
hands you look into her eyes and you
decide to spend the next uh 24 months on
a garage sale couch that cost thirteen
dollars and is pinkish blue but we're
not sure what color really
when you decide to do that you're going
to laugh about those days later
and uh you're certainly going to be but
it's actually going to the weird thing
is it's actually going to increase the
quality of your relationship and your
marriage more than the new couch will
by a hundred miles because we're working
together for a common goal and we're
sacrificing together for a common goal
and when you guys do that when you pay a
price for something you both believe in
early in your marriage together it knits
you together more beautifully than
buying everything looking perfect than a
hundred thousand dollar wedding a two
hundred thousand dollar car and a 300
000 new business
um and you know so a crummy wedding day
when it rains and the mushroom caps
float and the little thing and because
you did it outside and you didn't think
it was going to rain and that knits you
together a you know it sounds weird like
I don't want to sign you up for
suffering but you've already adopted it
so there you go you signed you up for
something so let's get after it so
working extra jobs living on a budget
the both of you being in agreement not
you dragging her along because you have
anxiety about debt but her being in
agreement that hey this is a mess we're
both going to work on this we're both
gonna lock arms we're going to put equal
emotional effort into it and we're going
to sacrifice to win for a short period
of time we're going to live like no one
else so that later we can live and give
like no one else
your business opening is going to be
down the line after you're out of debt
have an emergency fund saved and then
save up some money to start your
business right now you're just going to
work your butts off both of you and both
of you aren't working enough you got to
work more
here's another cool thing you'll buy a
different couch
in 30 months than you would right now
because you know how much a dollar is
worth and how much a thousand dollars is
worth and you're not going to buy a 5
000 couch yeah and so you I start doing
math if I'm you okay thirty three
thousand dollars a year it means I'm out
of debt in three years fifty thousand
dollars a year means I'm out of debt in
two years and how am I gonna do that
making 58 I got to make more money I
gotta have more money coming in and I
and I can't spend money on anything
because I don't have any money we're not
going out to eat we're not going on
vacation you're not going to see the
inside of a restaurant unless you're
freaking working there but guess what
you're the first Oh no you're the second
generation that thought you had to eat
out every night your first year of
marriage
every other generation the bride had the
pleasure of burning meals for a year
trying to figure it out
and then you can laugh about that too
and my wife is actually a good Southern
cook but she still screwed up a lot of
stuff the first year and you know how
much I screwed up none because I didn't
do nothing so there you go screwed that
up too so there you go but uh so I just
got the pleasure of her being mad when I
was making fun of her but anyway it's
all good so you know but no I mean this
is how life Works y'all it's okay it's
okay to for everything to not look like
Instagram because that's someone else's
highlight reel their kids still pooped
in the floor three minutes before they
did those little white suits and put
them all together
three minutes before
in the floor what are you thinking you
know they did I know those kids that
wear those white suits you know they did
that there's Cha-Cha everywhere in that
house everywhere
so yeah don't follow other people's
highlight reels sacrifice to win pay it
off now if you have a shared Vision very
detailed very laid out where both of you
are in agreement on it and then get your
butt in attack mode that'll be the best
thing ever happened to a young marriage
is to learn to accomplish goals together
through sacrifice through goal setting
through hard work you can do that you
can do anything my friend anything
nothing will stop you